the dark side of the universe is a
really big mystery the dark matter and
the dark energy make up no less than 96
percent of what the universe contains
the stuff that you and I
the Sun the Earth the Stars the galaxies
are made of that is just the icing on
the cake it makes up only four percent
of what a universe contains the most
likely explanation for the dark matter
is that it's made of some exotic
fundamental particle that came into
exist that's just a tiny fraction of a
second after our universe was formed in
the Big Bang but it is a mystery
we have compelling evidence that it's
there
we suspect
it's a fundamental particle but
frustratingly it has yet to be
discovered